all right gwendolyn
hi gwendolyn uh where'd you grow up
where are you from originally
um i am from a small farming town in
upstate new york called red hook um
it's a very small town i graduated with
only about a hundred kids
and tell me about your childhood you
have both your parents um yeah i grew up
with my mom my dad my sister
my well my older sister my older brother
and then my younger sister um and
my childhood honestly um it wasn't that
great
my mom was an abusive alcoholic um
she would you know physically abuse her
children
and she was very verbally and
emotionally
abusive towards us
yeah so what kind of stuff would she get
into
just um she would throw things a lot you
know if we like got
i mean we were kids but like even if we
like
spilled a glass of milk she would like
automatically start throwing things at
us
and like punching us in the face and um
that kind of stuff um she was very
verbally abusive when i was a teenager
she would tell me that i'm fat i'm a
loser i'm a horrible person
and just it was the worst years of my
life
so you you left home at what what age
um when i was 18 i left home and i
actually i lived in my car
in woodstock new york and kind of just
hung out there
for the summer um yeah
what kind of kid were you in high school
excuse me what kind of kid were you in
high school
um i was very shy
had a lot of social anxiety and making
friends and stuff i was kind of the
outcast for like the loner in high
school
and where's your life taking you since
since back then
um honestly i
my life since you know when i
left home at 18 it's just got and i mean
it's gotten worse but it's also gotten
better you know
um as you know a transgender woman it's
really
you know i face a lot of uh
discrimination and
a lot of places and you know
discrimination from my parents and my
siblings and
people from my school and um i you know
i
turned to drugs and alcohol for the
answer and it took me to a very
dark place that i thought i would never
get out of but um
eventually um about three months ago
i was able to get out of that and live a
happy and sober life
are you finding life as a transgender is
easier
on the west coast than it is absolutely
becky's
yeah i i lived in california about four
years ago
um which is part of why um i wanted to
leave new york and go to a treatment
facility that was in california
because i it was the atmosphere was just
so much more
um friendly and pleasant more accepting
accepting yes
are drugs a part of the picture for you
not anymore um
since then i i've you know i've been
sober um
from uh alcohol and heroin for about
three months now
where are you living now um i live in a
sober house
for you and how do you support yourself
um right now um my parents uh had a
trust fund set up for me
so i'm using money from that until i can
get a job which is very hard with
everything going on right now
so yeah that was a
tough time for everybody yeah
[Music]
have you had rough experiences being
transgender people would
um i have yes um
you know just like the discrimination of
like just
things people walking down the street
say to me or like
you know not getting jobs or i remember
even like in high school i faced a lot
of discrimination even from teachers and
students
and you know there's rehabs
treatment rehab centers that i've been
to where i had to face discrimination
even from a place that was supposed to
be helping me
but discriminated against me and said
and um
you know it was very it's been very
difficult you know
but um i've learned to um love myself
so you know whenever i do happen to face
discrimination i just let it go
because i know that um
i'm just a better person and that it
doesn't matter what other people say
about you
good for you that's got to be a real
challenge yeah
it's nice to hear thank you tell me
about the tattoo on your forehead
um i was homeless in denver colorado
um in 2018
um and i was was friends with these
other two homeless guys and i was
drinking and doing a lot of uh
heroin and i got drunk and i passed out
and i woke up with a tattoo on my
forehead that says
[ __ ] that was done with the sewing
needle
um at the time i really wasn't upset
about it because
i was like it doesn't really matter i'm
homeless and doing drugs no one's gonna
care
but um now it really bothers me really
bothers me
it's really hard to find a job i have to
constantly keep covering it with you
know makeup
and you know people in public asking me
what it says like just random strangers
on the street
just asking me like oh what's on your
forehead and then staring at my forehead
like
it really bothers me and you know um i'm
gonna get it removed
you know i haven't had it removed yet
because i was still actively using and
you know when you're actively using you
don't really care much about yourself
but
um i would like i'm going to get it
removed i already have like
looked up some places that you tattoo
removal that are open right now
yeah what what are the what have been
the most helpful things you've done to
help your
self-worth your self-image um
i did a lot of positive affirmations you
know just telling yourself that like
you're beautiful and that you're worth
it
um you find that it's almost like
brainwashing yourself to believe it
right
yeah it's hard because like i was
brainwashed for so long to think that
i'm a fat loser
so i just did the opposite that's
exactly i told myself that i was
beautiful and lovable
good for you um a lot i went to a lot of
therapy
um to work on you know my self-esteem
and um it took a while for me to realize
that it doesn't matter what other people
say about me
you know i'm my own person and i should
be happy with that yeah
how old are you i'm 23 23 so you're
still very young
good for you thank you i'm proud of you
thank you it's a lot to go through yeah
do you have friends um yes i'm friends
with the girls that are in my soaker
house i didn't really have friends in
high school
just because i was very shy and
didn't really know how to talk to people
about being so uncomfortable in your own
body
so i do have some really nice friends um
in sober living
what is you know you're only 23 but what
what lessons have you learned
you know from living you've been you've
been on the street for how long
um on and off for five years mostly on
yeah and you've been treated badly and
it sounds like sometimes what what
lessons have you learned
about others about people to never give
up
as much as it seems like it's never
going to get better
like after all the stuff that i've gone
through and
i thought it would never ever end but
there's always at some point it will end
and it will get better and you can have
a happy and fulfilling life
do you find your family is helpful or
supportive at this point um they're
giving you money which is good
um my siblings are really supportive my
younger sister
she's a lesbian and she's very
supportive my older
sister and older brother he's very
supportive the only people that aren't
really that supportive are my parents
they tolerate it but they don't accept
it
like they won't even talk about it with
me
but i kind of i don't let that bother me
though because you know what just
they don't have to you know accept me as
long as i
accept me exactly
it's across the board for everybody i
think yeah
awesome well gwendolyn thank you so much
for sharing your story yeah thank you
very very interesting talking with you
thank you
you